[Music]
welcome to hottie the show with the
horsey and the haas questions today we
have our good friend nigel
also known as uncle roger sometimes yes
hi yeah
so is it surreal you're on hot seat it's
like pretty unbelievable yeah yeah i
love this
what is this he spared no expense steve
i'm telling you man this is high quality
[ __ ] do you like game of thrones it's
real swords actually so all right so as
you know on hot seat we like to show us
we like to start the show with a cold
question or to make sure that people
leave the video quickly
oh the question yeah cold question okay
first time huh let's say
you are
walking
down
a very
safe neighborhood rule super safe okay
and then someone comes out of nowhere
and attacks you like this
okay what do you do
you just you know i don't know
protect myself
[Laughter]
it's like
training training
that's the real protection unsubscribe i
mean
that's just he can be poking somewhere
else not just your eyes you don't have
to try to justify it yeah it's okay we
could just it's just to warm you up a
little bit oh okay what's one of the
like uh most annoying uh hecklers that
you've had to like deal with hecklers
it's just been really good they they
people are nice so far on the tour but
the worst show i've had is that this
place in in the uk it's called butlins
it's a holiday holiday resort butlins
huh i mean it sounds terrible
people just go there and drink they're
drunk at 3 p.m that sounds awesome yeah
it sounds like the commerce casino they
they they just heckle the [ __ ] out of my
worst game i was supposed to do 20
minutes at that show i lasted eight
minutes on stage
did you excuse yourself did you like you
walked out walked yourself out or no i i
was like i'm gonna do my time but at the
point nobody was laughing they started
booing at minute five they were throwing
like the beer beer cups i mean the plus
thank god it's plastic thank god that's
good and then i was like no i'm gonna
get paid to do 20. i'm gonna do 20 to
get paid
by that the eight minute mark i saw a
security guard behind the curtain that's
just giving me this motion just get off
this motion what happened were there a
lot of drunk people just talking [ __ ]
for no reason very like
i wouldn't say they're racist maybe they
are they probably are but i don't know
but i was i would say they want a very
like a very insular they're very mob
mentality small town britain they want
to see
and they're drunk they want to see conor
mcgregor yeah no conor mcgregor is not
really he's irish they'll hate him too
so it's not racing how how uh how were
you how did you stay motivated after
that incident to keep doing stand up um
did that not crush you like oh my
crushes you for a day but then yeah but
it's like you i've bombed before and
it's become a great story if you search
like nigel ung butlins i have a six
minute routine i describe that resort as
it's a seaside resort that will make you
pro global warming when you see the
people there you're like
melt the ice cap drown those [ __ ] you
know yeah shout out to butlins you know
yeah butlins and i also described them
as uh it is in the bit as well they were
wearing um the shaved head and white
t-shirt that kind of get up the skin
head get up you know in the uk and i
call that the business casual version of
the kkk outfit
oh [ __ ] that was a that was a rough
roughest gig out there but apart from
that on my tour it's been amazing
san francisco a little bit quiet and
nerdy but that's the worst so it's fine
people come out to you to see you
because they like you right on twitter
so yeah that's pretty cool you never
smash the fans smack
sometimes you know
own it own it let's go
that's the best i like how fast he
answered that at least he owns it on
like this guy over here joe joe no you
sex haver i have a people pleaser you
know oh that's what it is
you went to school in northwestern um
but you didn't grow up here like what
brought you
to chicago to go to school i just i just
got a scholarship you're the smartest
book i'm okay i get by i get by did you
get a scholarship for for a degree
engineering [ __ ] engineering
did your parents go
i can't believe it you're not an
engineer you're a failure man what the
hell before encourage you blew up yes
really but like i just want to do a
stupid jokes all day
do they believe in the longevity or are
they doing that [ __ ] where they're like
this is a phase
now i think they're okay now because
they
only one they encourage the only thing
they laugh at because they can
understand him
i speak an asian accent right like mine
is a regular standout i sound like this
it's a bit fast too fast for them to get
they once you start talking about like
business casual kkk they're like what
what
what's the kkk
oh [ __ ] is it like you know like it's
like the video like 4k is that kind of
thing like high quality videos it's only
3k so it's not so good quality
[Laughter]
and then on youtube you can see the
subscriber number so that
he's just an engineer
he's famous
he has a full case what do your parents
do uh my mom's like semi-retired now so
is my dad my dad used to sell used cars
for a little bit you know they're not
very successful so i have to send them
money all the time
do you tell them that right what do you
tell them they're not very successful i
think i think they know themselves i
don't need to do you think they
pressured you harder because they
themselves were not
they didn't really pressure me really
yeah tiger mom is like a very western
asian thing you know
malaysia is a bit more chill we're not
like korea or china so i grew up pretty
good childhood so what motivated you to
get good grades i don't know i just like
being good at stuff wow i just grew up
whatever i did try to do my best at it
you know outside of comedy what else do
you feel like you're good at like do you
do anything else hobby sports pounding
my fans
a plus dude i'll give you a scholarship
uncle roger the nigel experience vip
tickets if we ever travel together just
remind me to get a hotel on the opposite
side of you yeah so i can get a [ __ ]
night of sleep
you guys have an uncle orgies dude
[Laughter]
you're gonna hear him critiquing oh
[ __ ] was better new york
oh god
what was like the uh most uh gratifying
for your own self that uh like came out
of the fan [ __ ]
experience fan pounding
uncle roger blew up what was like one of
the coolest things that came about from
that i've been hustling for like a
decade 10 years 11 years man you know
you do any sort of creative endeavor
you're not guaranteed a break yeah so to
be able to do what i do for a living and
you know live you know comfortably off
it it's like it's a good feeling man so
out of your 10-year hustle what year was
uh the viral
of your content encourage you went viral
july 2020
so i started doing stand-up 2011. so
i've been hustling nine years and then
attend that i quit my job went full-time
stand up six months before the pandemic
hit oh [ __ ] let me hear i lost all my
work i had like 10 months worth of
savings as runway otherwise i had run
off money and i had to go back to a day
job so i said okay let's try to make
something work in 10 months so are you
glad that you were doing stand-up
already
because you know there's this thing
where tubers sometimes they start doing
stand-up after they blow up i think they
can do stand-up have you seen
tick-tockers do stand up is the worst
man i want to watch it yeah it's bad but
the thing is who's your favorite no i
didn't actually
what are you talking about dude what
charlie damilio that sounds similar to
us our friend uh charlo fit
he was doing standard flight 10 years
and then he was pretty much serving
tables and all that
and he was and he's so funny but he was
just hustling hustling hustling and it
wasn't until he created his cholo fit
character which is like this guy that's
a cholo which is like a hispanic
gangster that teaches people how to
exercise oh that's funny and then it
blew up
and then from there it was just like
tv show signed by a production company
and so i'm so proud of him but it was
just crazy that he was just like 10 15
years of stand-up just kind of going
nowhere you know and all it took was
just that one big break funny talented
dude yeah so then he had the skills to
back up the opportunity in those ten
years you develop your chops right
otherwise you get big on tick tock you
you do a stand-up show people will come
see you once
if they come to the show they don't like
it then they okay we saw him we don't
want to see him anymore right but
hopefully people come i do have people
who come to the show and then they come
to another show i told them i tell them
the same material but they're still
coming they still love it uncle roger
because that does crowd work so every
time i [ __ ] on different people
do you change your set at all or does it
evolve for you or are you really happy
with where it's at mine are evolving
always improving it but this tour the
haya tour right now is going to be
roughly 90 of the same material every
show you come to 80 90 so you worked on
it bit by bit and then you developed
your kind of touring material and then
you're touring with it just kind of like
touring with the feature film or
something yeah and then when it's done i
record the special and then retire the
material and then you bring out a new
set you wrote everything you have no
writing partner or anything no no no
just sometimes in a car ride with other
comedians you would kind of risk
yeah and then you come out with new
lines or you just you know ask a
comedian friend to watch your set they
give you a few pointers oh you could say
this usa this year but maybe for my next
tour because it will have to happen in
like two or three years time maybe i'll
get some writing help to you know more
eyes move it faster yeah have you faced
that kind of uh criticism like are you
just a [ __ ] youtuber
you're not a real stand-up comedian oh
yeah definitely there's a stigma there
but who cares right yeah i sell tickets
i make money and then the people who
don't do youtube well good luck having a
career in this dance
that's a great yes late night that's
nothing anything with a shiny floor yeah
that's nothing for you anymore
shiny floor you'll find yourself on a
shiny floor you're irrelevant
you're like oh [ __ ] it's true the only
way shiny floor works if you if you take
it out and put it on youtube then it
goes goes viral then the shiny floor but
if you if you have too shiny for your
friend's like nah this is a shiny floor
you're not relatable yeah it feels
outdated right on tick tock you see
shiny floor you just scroll through it
true yeah you're gonna see big tits in
the ring light that's why there's sticks
i mean hey that's very true so a lot of
uh people that do comedy it's like their
form of
coping or something painful that
happened and that's like their new
perspective if you have to i don't know
if this is the case for you but like
let's say if you had to tie it to
anything that was painful or traumatic
in their childhood like what would you
think helped you have this funny
perspective
um i never had that traumatic of a
childhood i think i was beating my
parents whatever you all were right yeah
i was not you were not
that's not true they hugged me really
hard sometimes it's hard to breathe
[ __ ] ass sounds like you're bragging
and they gave me money
oh too much love it's constricting and
i'm like oh yeah let me crack my neck
first
it's like a bear hug i mean that's one
way to view it as a coping thing but
sometimes if you
it's not really that because if you just
view comedy as comedy as a copy thing
that you do very depressing comedy you
talk about how your dad touched you and
when you're going oh
yeah that gets old waiting for the
button
is there a button what the dad touching
and therefore he wants you to sit in the
line oh that's not bad
yeah and it's all yeah i know exactly
comedy is about like
everything that happens in my life right
so i i thought two years ago i got
punched in london it's like a suspected
thing you can't prove people's attention
right but i was just on my street you're
like you got covered i know he just said
you know what you did you know what you
did you were just walking along the
street god oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] sounds
like an american
i haven't gotten punched here yet so
that you got wait london has an oakland
too
oakland london
the punching asians everywhere is it
global what do you think of ronnie chang
oh yeah i love him he's so funny can we
do that again can you [ __ ] it on him a
little should i hear him
he's like
he's also malaysian yes oh really yeah
yeah but he grew up in many different
places he to me we have a lot of like
similar life experience but i always
feel him and he's like the smarter one
his comedy is very like insightful i
thought he was an australian or
something he lives in australia oh
is there is there like a particular like
um for asian stand-up comedians like a
particular type of asian joking that
like many do that you just like really
don't like these like kind of overrated
or played out um
my father-in-law loves joy koi for
example yokoi is great joker is great
i mean ev every that the hacky jokes of
course yeah uh like if your punchline is
just you know a stereotype dance my dick
is small yeah yeah that's [ __ ] funny
no i was just i just felt like
mentioning good
funny because it's true you know you
love it
i love what asian guys say that about
them
one criticism i get is like people don't
sometimes people don't like the the
accented character and then they quote
this bow burn i'm quote like oh when you
do an asian accent is white people think
you're laughable now you're giving them
permission to laugh at you and then both
of that yeah people always leave but
don't a lot of people speak like that in
malaysia that's that's how you [ __ ]
sound so why are you taking uh asian
comedy advice from bo burnham first of
all we're gonna see a white guy explain
you know cultural comedy too and
second of all like no like
in asia a lot of us sound like that i
don't think my mom's laughable you know
that's uh coming up with a white baggage
thing right uh but yeah my comedy is
just about everything that happens in my
life and i talk about the hate crime
stuff i made it funny it's not
depressing so it's a funny funny story
it was funny even without commentary
yeah you just put different music to
those clips
you had me and my dad touched me i'm
like
you see your dad touch you other asian
kids like why your dad touched you wow
my dad never talked to me yeah
i felt zero effectively we've reached
the 14 minute 35 second mark which this
is where we like to turn up the heat oh
[ __ ] so um you know obviously didn't
come from a lot of pain that's not what
informed your comedy nah um but do you
have a great life regret something that
you're like damn i mean
you had a failed marriage uh yeah maybe
you'll talk about that or a successful
divorce
it's a failed marriage or a successful
divorce
and a successful divorce she didn't take
any of my [ __ ] that's pretty cool
that's why i was still friends you mean
like your comedy material or your
actions
[Music]
what if the judge does that it goes
she's gonna have to take half your
material now
you're like no not half of my set
you can take the setups she takes the
punchline
you have to tour together
that's a funny reality show isn't it
dude
take half the material that you have to
perform the ex-wife you hate dude you
can have it you could have it yeah it's
a funny sitcom but then you fall back in
love maybe yeah that could be a nice
rom-com
yeah
nobody wants to see a happy ending and
so no regrets
anytime regrets i well there's gotta be
requests i think in my 20s right you're
chasing this comedy thing and then i was
performing so for a bit of context i'll
have i had my day job nine to six
and then 6 p.m i just take a train up to
birmingham a city in the uk perform get
back home like midnight sleep repeat
four or five nights a week what was your
day job uh i worked at a tech startup so
unfortunately the san francisco guys i'm
one of them you know that's why you know
that's why you could do the laptop jokes
that's why that's why you know exactly
when to say github yeah exactly so i
miss a lot of my friends like weddings
and birthday parties you know but i
think you're even chasing a dream that's
kind of the sacrifice you have to make
but they're gonna they're gonna get
another birthday and another birthday
sometimes another marriage and i hear i
hear like weddings are not fun to go to
sometimes so maybe i dodge a bullet
there you know oh you never been to any
no actually i've never been to like a
proper ceremony no no no because i also
don't live in malaysia so all my close
friends are back in malaysia if i
weren't doing comedy i might have been
able to like just fly back to my clothes
were you too busy for your own wedding
no
we just did a courthouse thing oh word
we wanted to save up for like a
proper marriage but then i always
i never see saw the value in it and i
wanted to get this comedy career going
and i'm waiting certainly what 30 40
grand minimum yeah so to me that savings
that i could put towards my career now
if i want to put on a ceremony sure i
can have some savings now but at the
time i was a struggling artist i
couldn't it's like five butlins
yeah i mean that that bad show you did
that bad resort oh five butlins
results 250 pounds man what's the part
of comedy that's uh
rewarding to you
so much so
where you're willing to like quit your
job move cross-country like live this
like nomadic life like what about it do
you love so much uh it's pounding the
fans
yes i knew it i was waiting
you're always gonna get a [ __ ]
applause here for that man that's
awesome we're fan pounders here you ever
pull up your own videos with a fan in
the room and then you just take her from
behind
this is hot seat guys we don't ask like
[ __ ] stupid
i'm gonna try that i'm gonna try that
next time
it works dude i gotta say one of my
favorite things to do uh is you you so
you're with somebody new who knows that
you on the tubes and stuff and then you
pull up your own video and then you
start to you start to watch it in the
room with them and then you see how long
they're going to last before they say
something about it
just to [ __ ] with them well just to make
them think like you love watching
yourself and it's like oh dude
doesn't that get you right there oh just
watch this right here all right
i'll wait for this part wait for this
yeah
i think i'll just go soft man
see yourself
yeah it just goes soft goes off
yeah has a fan ever asked you to wear
the orange polo
they yes they have and
what do you say to that you do say you
say yes you're like thank you for being
here and being naked i'll do whatever
you ask for you know that's that's cool
that's a gentleman i don't believe you i
kind of believe you right now well it's
i mean she was funny and i thought it
was a funny thing i said okay let's try
it you know we just laughed a lot it
wasn't sexy
it was a joke yeah it was a joke we both
know it was a joke she wasn't sincere in
asking but i did have someone during sex
you just call out roger instead of nigel
it was like real that was and then did
you go ah
who the [ __ ] is roger
oh wait oh [ __ ] sorry
dude fans are [ __ ] crazy so i'll tell
you some [ __ ] off i'll tell you some
[ __ ] off camera but i i've known many a
tuber fortunately and unfortunately and
i'll i'm gonna tell you a [ __ ] crazy
story oh why we gotta go
on patreon guys
[Music]
you